don't you worry colt mccoy
will play on sunday night and nbc
will get what it wanted when it flexed
into this game which is a cult mccoy
revenge game
hope we'll go ahead 100 yards yes i
don't know if that's winning colt mccoy
revenge game four words that 2020 needed
to hear
next up brady quinn revenge game
let's go is there such a thing let's
bring him in uh kyle brent here on the
rich eisen show uh is there such a thing
as a spurgeon win
revenge game what do you think well i
think you have to start with the charlie
frye
uh revenge game yes and there's there's
so many
things there's a tim couch revenge game
there's a
help me out here who are we have white
hearse it's charlie whitehurst revenge
game yeah
uh jeff garcia revenge game derek
anderson
revenge game uh it's a fantastic slate
of revenge game starting of course
on sunday night on nw
how you doing kyle what's going on in
your mind everything good um
happy holidays happy chanukah rich um
this is that time of year it's great to
talk to you it is great to talk to you
what was i
i missed this morning's broadcast which
uh what what uh
what was on your plate today kyle it's a
funny thing you mentioned about the
giants
because this is how fickle everything is
i i would say
one week ago on our broadcast i'm sure
at least in part yours rich
yes oh man everything was coming up
giants and big blue
and this is great and joe judge is
cracking skulls and they're gonna win
and they're gonna pull off this thing
and then about midway through that game
this thing
the giant so-called bandwagon fell off
the table this was like a
a season two of true detective this is
like
when came out with that the reason is
you song everybody just
fleeing like rats like nobody is on the
giants now it's all coming up washington
but i think of colt mccoy when's the
sunday it's like well
the math says we're back it's a wild
time to be a giants fan
well i mean the browns are also a
perfect example of it when they were
down by two scores middle of the
the monday night game i'm thinking to
myself well at least i parsed everything
i said about the browns over the last
five days is like well this may not age
well
um but i i you know i i think to take
out of that monday night game
is that the lamar of 2019
arrived in 2020 for the first time we
didn't even see it
maybe even in week one uh when they boat
raced cleveland
um that that they arrived and that
cleveland just
if if they come up with a stop here or
stop there
they they can put up a whole bunch on
you and and run all over you
yeah you know we saw it the week before
with lamar but it's dallas
so it was like the uh you know dicaprio
and django where he says
you had my curiosity now you have my
attention that's right i guess
he got our attention this week and
listen
they're going to the playoffs the ravens
are going to the playoffs the slate is
ridiculous that they have to play
lamar is totally in and on and it looks
like number eight the mvp
they're going and i think cleveland is
going to go with them
pittsburgh is going that's going to be
when we all when the schedule comes out
we say
what division's going to send two teams
three teams i think the north is sending
three teams
and i said that my take away from that
game rich when they finally scored and
they they made the go ahead kick with
justin tucker
i think there were two seconds left on
the clock and then there were safety
shenanigans and whatnot
i think if there were 15 seconds i think
baker could have gone down and scored
again
like that's how hot he was he was that's
how reeling the ravens defense was it
was truly
whoever has the ball last and i came
away that night being like
damn it baker mayfield is good and you
know what
if i could soapbox it just a little bit
there's baker maple's a very easy target
he's the number one of our pick he's
brash he's a wise ass he's in a lot of
commercials
it is very easy to knock him down there
are people we both know who
have been making their careers the last
couple years on knocking him down
you want followers you want listeners
just bash baker may for a while and
people will like it
i'm sorry but he can play yes he threw
an interception that night it was his
first one in about six weeks
baker mayfield is really good and baker
mayfield could be sitting here with a
playoff win
in about a month i agree with you uh
however i am
mandated to have to hold your feet to
the fire
by saying if the ravens make it who
doesn't because they're right now
uh in the category that sadly we're
still the only
organization that's calling the in the
hunt category
sniffing it um so right now
they're sniffing it which team that's
currently in is a wild card doesn't make
it because the ravens do
dolphins or colts which one do you
choose there or even the titans if they
fall out had a bad night with the ravens
winning
uh a very bad night um it's
tricky rich because i really believe in
flores
and i'm having a very difficult time
saying you know what
i'm gonna ride phil rivers i think he
can make it it's just
he's let me down many times before right
always volatile he's the perfectly named
person he is like a turgid
roaring river up and down up and down so
i have to choose between one of them in
this conversation and i guess i'm going
to choose
i think i'm going to have to choose the
colts and just roll the dice with philip
rivers because they run
and they hit and like they got a score
to settle in their own division because
tennessee smacked them around for a
while but i still think
if i have to choose one it's going to be
the colts miami had a bad night with
that ravens
so the colts make it you think the
dolphins will will be the ones that
that are on the outside looking in
because yeah you know obvious you're
assuming that they do
find the joe judge giants in more of
pumpkin mode than carriage mode in week
16 baltimore
which is sandwiched uh in between
jacksonville this week and at cincinnati
to wrap it up
miami has got new england vegas in
buffalo and they're at vegas and at
buffalo
so if you know the ravens do win out
that would mean that miami
loses just one and they'd be out that's
that's probably where you you'd have to
sit right now
right you've got so many plates in the
air rich and you're just
nailing them and it's so difficult but i
think the takeaway when you put it like
that
is that if you're one of these teams
that needs baltimore to lose even let's
even include the raiders in that let's
they they need baltimore to lose badly
who you're rooting for for the next
three weeks you're rooting for
gardner-minshew
uh maybe ryan finley if he's
and then maybe daniel jones but i hear
as i'm waiting on hold to come in he's
got another injury like that that's a
that is not the the 27 yankees of
quarterbacks that you want to come in
and win the game for you it's tough
now yeah i mean kyle brant here on the
rich hasn't show jacksonville has
a role to play here um and and so many
fronts because they're at baltimore home
for chicago at
indianapolis and all three of those
teams still are have hopes they're
they're
you know indianapolis is the only one
currently in a playoff spot chicago
now suddenly sniffing it in the nfc
and that's where i'd like to land here
um because jacksonville also playing a
role in
who might get trevor lawrence as well
and i kind of you know i knocked on the
league's door and found out if the jets
and the uh and the jaguars are both one
and 15
and that's a that would not go the jets
way
uh it would go jacksonville's way based
on strength of schedule the way it
currently looks and the way that it most
likely would wind up so
that's pretty big hold up because i i
had heard that i know it's complicated
yeah
you checked in with the league if they
both end one in 15
jacksonville gets the number one pick it
goes to strength of schedule
in whichever team has the easiest
strength of schedule
would be the ones that gets the first
overall pick because here
it would mean that you sucked the worst
against the least of competition
it it actually counts against you to
suck terribly against better competition
it's kind of like you know your golf
game you're not supposed to hit a ball
hard and for it to go very far it's
counterintuitive here swing easy
yeah right and so right now believe it
or not what would count against the jets
remarkably when it all comes down to it
is they choose
the one year to go so bad
in the year in which the afc east
suddenly gets much better than it ever
was
and that the jacksonville jaguars have
four and nine
houston sitting in there and that leads
to their benefit
that's the way it currently looks right
now see this i find this immediately
compelling
never i'm all the sudden into it never
mind the packers and saints and the
chiefs i like this
riddle me this yes what happens week 17
if the new york jets are uh on 15th yes
and bill belichick surmises
that losing to the jets that day
could actually help the jaguars get
trevor lawrence
thus keeping him out of the afc east is
that not the chess move that belichick
makes with a team that's most likely
mathematically eliminated kyle
look there's many reasons why i think
we're simpatico okay there's many
reasons why
i adore having you on this show every
single wednesday there's many different
ways
that you being a princeton man and me
going to
the ivy of the midwest known as michigan
that we're that we're lockstep
we actually have been talking about this
very moment i love it
for days as a matter of fact we had tom
curran of uh
nbc sports boston when we gave that
concept
to him and asked him what belichick
would do what did he call that chris he
said he was writing it down because it
was
uh it's a talker that's what he said
it's a talker it's a talker that's what
it is
uh because it would run completely kind
of talk about counterintuitive
completely against bill belichick to lay
back in any way shape or form let alone
against the jets
part of me thinks that he would love to
stick the jets with the
uh ignominy of an owen 16 that they
would join
the tampa bay buccaneers of the 70s and
the lions and the
the uh the browns of the arts and teens
that he would love to stick them with
that but if it means
no trevor lawrence in his division um
that's a talker which we're talking
about
it's great i is not occurred to me you
guys are ahead of me on this and that's
the perfect person to ask and current
i just feel like you don't need the um
brilliant ernie adams somewhere in the
catacombs of foxborough new england
coming up with new ideas and rules for
belichick as he has
been for years and bread and water in
the laboratory down there
this one's an obvious one my question is
if belichick were to elect this strategy
to say look
i can pin him on 16 sure that'd be fine
bunch of people have gone on 16 before
you just named him rich and nobody ever
lost out on trevor lawrence
this is the art of war stuff i'd rather
have them win
and in winning lose i wonder how far he
would go with that are we going to see
stidhum uh week 17 are we going to see
the squad player how much could he get
away with it this is the game of the
season as far as i'm concerned
wildcat yeah could go wildcat
like power eye wing t like let's go yeah
you know
but then did the jets return fire and do
they start
they're not smart enough people are
playing they're not smart enough to
return fire
now something's up when we'll know
something's up when belichick says we
need to see what we have in brian hoyer
you know that's when we'll smell around
i love it
kyle brandt here on the rich eisen show
and you know we just talked about you
know
next level uh chicanery potentially uh
to try and uh keep a team from
successfully tanking um let's talk about
you as a bears hunk sir
this past week seeing trubisky look the
way that he looked and against
desean watson of all people okay
obviously it's a texans defense but
desean watson
in the building and the bears defense
taking care of him
do you think this is the future
or would you say it's a mirage and you
would prefer the bears to just keep on
losing so a house gets cleaned
what do you think kyle i remember
vividly our conversation
uh in september when
you were on one as the kids say rich
about
the short leash that was on miss
trubisky by matt maggie
and we joked it was like one of those
handheld retractable leeches with you
know the blue bag of crap on the bottom
of it there's like a real
pot leash that he had on him and it's so
unbelievably complicated because that
was the right move to pull him that day
it was the right because nick foles
coming to beat the falcons and
everything looked great
then nick foles was terrible for what
felt like in terminally about two years
and now mitch who is a master of
avoiding the breakup it is the person
the boyfriend you're
just about to break up with and all of a
sudden you've got a candlelight dinner
and you've hired yoni
to play next to the table like he knows
how to be unfireable
and so to that question your question my
roundabout way of answering is
i love mitch i've seen enough of mitch i
am not going to take a couple nice
throws down robinson against houston
texas to say
one more year or five more years no i i
think
we've made our bed with mitch and i
think we've already slept in it it's
been terrible restless sleep i think it
is time to move on i do not
i'm not ready for mitch in 2021 so bears
vikings i mean
it's on right i mean they're they're
they're both sniffing it at six and
seven this is a big
football game and then of course you
know the end of the season against green
bay there's that game against
jacksonville as we mentioned
jacksonville is going to play a large
role here
they're gonna look good against
jacksonville and then uh
here we go i mean like so you're you're
you're not thinking that the bears could
actually sneak in at seven
make some hay maybe you know do
something against the rams potentially
similar to what we saw you know in the
regular season couple
years ago when when uh you know the
double doink hit and all of that
business
i mean you don't you don't want to see
that you don't want to be all in on that
how dare you utter the words double
doing rich we just had to go through the
cody park
cleveland he missed two more kicks i
know he's kicking like he wanted to get
today
that's about to say he wanted to get
back on the today show he missed it yeah
yeah that's what you do after you miss a
kick that's a time and place
he uh double linked both of those two
listen the the chicago bears lost six
games in a row
baby steps i know this is the season of
miracles right now
but enrich and i love that your voice
starts to rise when you say
win another one and another one gonna
get in when
i need a little more i'm not gonna sit
here and do backflips because they beat
the texans the texans are terrible
no i'm not gonna do it and i don't think
they will do it i
i i'm not gonna bs you because i'm born
in the chicago suburbs no i never do
that i i'm
very very jaded when it comes to 20 20
bears sure i'd love to see it don't
expect it kyle brandt before we let kyle
brandt go
the poll question christopher ask him
this is uh this is a good one today
chris
ask him the poll it's important it's the
most important question you'll answer
today kyle
it's the 26th anniversary of dumb and
dumber's release
unbelievable yep it's the best fairly
brothers movie
dumb and dumber kingpin something about
mary
oh my god what a good question um
summer of 1998 i am
19 years old and the college freshman i
went
to see a movie called there's something
about mary and
it is when they reveal the
the pieces of flesh that were in the
zipper they do a whole scene and then
show it it is by far the hardest i've
ever laughed inside a cinema i left my
chair i was on my knees and that
disgusting sticky floor with all the
concessions and i got to tell you
the second hardest i've ever laughed in
the theater cameron diaz
is that is that hair gel that's the
second so they the fairly brothers in
one movie have the two
biggest guffaws i have ever had in a
theater and i love those other movies
don't sleep on kingpin woody harrelson
saying i took the cat liberty uh milk in
your cow for you
she sure is a stubborn one we don't have
a cow you know the punch line
unbelievable movie but my answer with
respect to lloyd christmas and harry
dunn yes
is there something about mary change the
whole game
you know what um and then we didn't even
talk about chris elliott in that
um and his role in that film uh
obviously
ben stiller and then brett favre um
apparently you know the farrelly
brothers will say they try to get steve
young right they try to get steve young
to do it
drew bledsoe um i think there was some
there was a big huge
uh fight that involved bledsoe or
something like that you were at a
concert
supposedly and drew got injured or
something yeah
he wasn't supposed to be there i know
and so you know farv
kind of had the had the brady roll right
because
bledsoe couldn't answer the bell i mean
they're telling that whole story
um and i'll just remember cameron diaz
when she showed up on the screen for the
first time
it was that was the end of that
pretty much and and i remember too
also i was on sportscenter year two for
me
back in 1998 and when she said you know
on the date that can't we just go watch
sportscenter the whole newsroom
came back in the next day and we're like
did you hear what cameron diaz said
in in uh in something about mary all
that said though kyle
i voted for kingpin kingpin is great oh
my god
that's my favorite moment rich from
kingpin
when bigger and mccracken in his and his
comb over got that much worse and they
just cut to the cutaway of
bill murray's cut uh his comb over just
so uh
that's the end honestly just that one
shot bigger
is above the law one of the greatest
characters in movies he wins a million
dollars and he says i now have enough
money to buy my way out of anything
[Music]
and talk about it
talk about the piece of sports
memorabilia from a movie you'd want
the bowling ball with the rose in the
middle oh my god gorgeous roses come on
and then uh and i wouldn't i wouldn't
sneeze at roy munson's plastic hand
either
i mean the iowa state championship ring
on it no less oh my gosh
kyle thanks for the call appreciate it
um your podcast
your podcast available on spotify and
ringer of the uh first several episodes
sitting right there
when do you come back uh with a new
episode on uh next year and wednesday
strategizing about that rich i think
right in the heart of the uh the
national football league playoffs in
mid-january we're lining up contestants
and uh season two is going to be a very
very fun it's a game show it's talk show
it's everything rich likes i like
really i love it i love it kyle
appreciate the time we'll chat next
wednesday as well
um and we'll see you on good morning
football and the rest of the gang
tomorrow and every single weekday at 7
eastern time on nfl network thanks for
the time kyle just great we'll get
munson down in the middle of nowhere
there you go let's count
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here